[Music]
insects spell news 30 mine say what's up
to the homie you know [ __ ] wrong with
you guys it's aired out and then
explodes yeah whatever the boss wants
right dude we when we were when we're in
France this perv was eyeballing
Cristina's boobs like super hardcore
yeah making fun of them and he put his
scarf over and you started jacking off
in front of what it's like a train and
everyone was watching someone recently
event caught you recording him yeah that
was yeah it was a good but he didn't
care now he just kept staring at
Christina's boobs like on the train the
train in France yeah so he saw me
recording Christina but he didn't really
care so he saw the phone and then he
just went back to her boobs oh my gosh
when she covered it with a scarf then he
like started going like x-ray vision
through the sky did you know that
[Laughter]
interest went to another girl I miss
[ __ ] espresso and croissants though
oh yeah we gotta go back
alright this is by the way submitted by
Peter answers alright yeah Fidel can't
appear this professional sex which makes
it you living testing spells to help her
clients boost their or again oh my god
booster there's always dumb [ __ ] that
will fall for anything always how do you
boost with magic girl base cell which
incantations and spells and voodoo [ __ ]
on eBay
like for $20 I will cast a spell on blah
blah and I don't need it that was dude
over the [ __ ] Internet like whoever
buys the [ __ ] dumbest [ __ ] ah maybe
it works we went to all those temples
you could buy all those charms yeah it
was like buy this paper thing for 10
bucks yeah we bought was something
physical you know like it's cute I can
make use of it you know so this is not
even physical no this is like pay me 20
bucks I'll just chant into a [ __ ] air
and your lover will fall in love with
you it's just giving 20 bucks for no
more you know he's chatting demons in
you and [ __ ] alright yeah I really wish
though in this world powers like that
did exist it would be so now be so good
I'll be [ __ ] David because we are not
good I was obsessed with matilda and
sabrina the teenage please tell me it's
only special because like it's unique
like no one else has the power right but
when everyone has it it's just gonna be
normal like talent today yeah so talent
is magic today so if you could you know
play ball really well that's the magic I
know I want tell me we'd be cursed so
hard we're not good people we would get
curses put on us like someone would be
watching right now and she's a witch
she's like I [ __ ] hate these people
and she curse all I will say this though
about talent like I really hate it when
people applaud people for just doing
normal [ __ ] yeah you do that you do it
for children right [ __ ] adult you
should be able to differentiate between
talent and did you just suck you know I
mean as a kid you boost their town you
give them self-esteem you help them out
but now adults want that [ __ ] too
you know like the A for effort kind of
[ __ ] it's like no you're an adult now
you should know you [ __ ] suck you
know what I mean
yeah when you're a kid like you know you
you ate your little piece of pumpkin and
we're like weird like this girl post a
photo she's like oh my man brought me
coffee and a sandwich at work today I
love him and then someone retweets ed
gold I might really go like you're
setting the bar on the ground at this
that's a goal that's a [ __ ] golden
year what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you're setting the bar to me is a normal
relationship work you do appreciate it
you don't take it for granted but you're
supposed to do those things
hmm it's not like happy Valentine's Day
I bought you [ __ ] lunch that's why I
like straight up men like every year I
get invited to judge a talent show and
then there's just kids they come out and
they're like yo man this guy's like
super talented can you listen to his
music and you know they know me as a
person on YouTube my stall my hey man
you're pretty bad you know and they're
like oh no he's not that bad listen do
you would you listen to a [ __ ] if it was
on the radio yes or no it's like no and
he's not good they're like he's good
enough for a college student in a talent
not even that oh really
yeah you know what I mean I was like
like number one the dude like he can't
[ __ ] catch a beat to save his life he
can't even strum the guitar on rhythm
he's off-key what makes you think he's
talented like he's it's dope I'm glad
he's doing it that's really cool and he
could be surrounded by a bunch of non
talented people
thank you yeah and someone in the
comments right now is gonna say well
David who the [ __ ] are you talking about
even that great of a singer it's like
yeah but you can tell if someone's bad
you don't got to be a [ __ ] great
singer yeah someone's shitty yeah my
thing about that too is just like my
thing is like I support it like I'm glad
you're doing what you love but don't
expect me to tell you that you're a
[ __ ] amazing get mad if I don't like
that's just all that it is so anyways
about this sex which let's get into the
details yes she her name is Shay me
she's 31 years old from New Zealand and
the former stripper and so okay there's
a lot of sexual energy all over her
witness she has the [ __ ] [ __ ] magic
dude all night just like this yes so
right now she's making a living of
coaching people on pagan erotic erotic
sysm erotica the [ __ ] is that
all I all I picture is girls [ __ ]
finger-banging themselves at Stonehenge
pagan mean it's me it's like before
yeah like before the religion we know
now it's like when why people used to be
like Asians and Africans and everybody
else I see before they had Christianity
all godless I think that's
godless or something like that when they
used to believe in like the nature magic
and all that stuff but the whole thing
is that though is that she does cast
spells and that she says that these
spells can boost orgasms and apparently
she's a pansexual and also an ecosexual
which means she gets Bucks trees nature
videos it's weird she gets turned on by
nature like fruits and stuff or like
actual nature okay I wonder what kind of
nature like I've seen a video of like
all these white people and they're all
white like actually no those one Asian
Hills really confuse like he didn't
wanna be there but they're like rubbing
dirt all over themselves and they're
naked I want say yes and they're
marrying a tree and they're [ __ ]
rubbing grassle themselves god damn it
you guys I'm happy cool it makes them
happy go ahead god damn you guys are
weird how the [ __ ] not cool I think it's
funny you know the whole thing about the
strip club is she oh she was saying that
back in ancient times that there used to
be temples where men would go seek
counsel and healing from erotic dancers
but that now it's all been distorted
because now it's all the powerplay and
she's saying that it's no longer a place
of love and so she decided it never was
I know exactly what she's talking about
and I think it was Marion or Babylonian
during the Harvest Festival there it was
an honor for females I think from the
farming class or whatever to go to the
temple and become temple hookers and so
to guarantee a good harvest or whatever
they would go into the temples to have
sex with these like young girls and then
pay the temple money but it's a form of
religious prostitution like porn has
desensitized that's true though hmm and
she's saying that spirituality is the
best way and it helps to recondition
ourselves with erotic subtleties and so
yeah I don't know I kind of I kind of
get it it's like the commercialism of
humans and sex is now just a transaction
of money and like
Plus where maybe she's trying to like
make it us religious or spiritual
experience and she's trying to flip the
script and make her I don't know I I
kind of think it's cool now at first I
was like this is a moonstone [ __ ] you're
trying to [ __ ] him make a vibrator out
of crystals and [ __ ] by people but then
if she's trying to change the experience
of it that's kind of cool too
it's like some Kama Sutra stuff how much
does an escort cost and do you do
escorts have sex with you my friend is
an escort and she charges up to three
thousand dollars just to go to dinner
with holy [ __ ] she better be [ __ ]
hella fine breathe I mean does she have
great conversations or what that's just
for dinner dude is she like a Victoria's
Secret Angel kind of if I paid $3,000
for it
escort there better be some sexual
activity that dinner that dinner you
were going to Joe under the table that's
what conversation with this guy that uh
she she she escorted with in the past
but he turn out to be a jerk if she
didn't want to do him anymore so he's
like and he's like desperately trying to
go back like how about I take you to
your favorite steak house and pay 3k she
still turned that down Wow
just for conversation I would stake at
three thousand dollars for somebody I
don't give a [ __ ] I love you like what
the [ __ ] we're not friends
I actually was we were male escorts
respect me so ladies do it for the steak
and that's how you trigger David oh my
god oh my god I have such high standards
lower your standard male entertainers
for a gay man yet accidentally
well it's essentially what and we had a
grand old time we came home and we
realized yeah we were you toys we were
we were used and I'm like for just for
our conversation any but a state and I'm
like this was amazing is this was like
to be a hot [ __ ] it's nobody won when
guys are like oh she's a [ __ ]
horrible blonde she's doing this room my
name like the moment that that gets
turned on you yeah guarantee you yeah
never condemn the woman for going out
for steak yep yeah mistake when I won't
Mara and I were first dating right she
had like this very poor perception of
like understanding when a guy was
hitting on her to get something from her
right and so like no joke that was the
first place that she was working when we
were together
a guy asked her out to dinner bla bla
bla and he was making like sexual
innuendos and she was like oh my god I
can't believe you did that did you think
was gonna happen
of course I was like did he buy your
dinner yes you know next time he wasn't
in ER did you say no but you got a good
meal mm-hmm yeah no one buys me dinner
next time man Shanee she looks different
in every picture
she's very magical is that it that's a
plant behind all those girls that might
be no shame in they smell yeah all those
girls have trouble coming it's weird
I don't know if they have trouble coming
but I would love to just watch this
session play out yeah I guess it looks
weird it's like a luminous circle-jerk
yeah
what is your [ __ ] represent my [ __ ]
represents a lion it radiates the lights
of love and joy out of my vagina yeah so
that's not one of those things know what
you do though let's tell you you're not
hurting anyone but goddamn it's weird
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]
you